good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Jessica Ma and I'm an assistant
professor at the Albert Einstein College
of Medicine here in New York
um good afternoon welcome to my webinar
um I'd like to thank the organizers of
bioconference live for the opportunity
to talk about my research today although
this is a webinar I just wanted to
mention that this is an interactive
webinar so I'd really like you to submit
your questions both during and after the
presentation I'd really welcome feedback
and ideas and and questions that you may
have so I'm going to get started the
title of my presentation is
investigating tissue specific networks
of cancer-causing mutations
and basically the starting point for my
talk is to step back and consider how
complicated we are as human beings so we
know that the human body consists of
over 200 highly specialized cell types
and when we look at these cells cell
types that they're incredibly diverse
they differ in terms of morphology in
terms of plasticity tone over rates
etc etc and what's really remarkable
when we consider the amount of diversity
present is that most cell types share
the same genome so that the diversity
we're actually seeing is a result of
epigenetic modifications and
transcription Factor networks so if we
want to understand what are the genes
that are driving the differences that we
see between cell types we really need to
start by looking at its transcriptional
profile
now when we think about cancer we often
talk about cancer in terms of its
discrete States like prostate cancer
breast cancer lung cancer but when we
really think about it cancer is a
systems level disease so if we think
about us as humans as the system cancer
is a disease that targets different
parts of the system and it's made up of
a broad spectrum of diseases that all
share in common this aspect of
unregulated cell growth
so when you think about cancer as a
perturbation of our different organs or
tissue types or even cell types there
are over 200 different types of
perturbations or different cancer types
that affect the human body now when you
think about it from this perspective a
question that that comes up
automatically is why are some tissues
more robust than others uh
at combating these perturbations to the
system so when we think about talking
about cancer in terms of breast cancer
prostate cancer tumors arise in in a
highly tissue specific manner
so when we think about germline
mutations a germline mutation is defined
as any change in a gene in a
reproductive cell so for instance like
an egg or a sperm that's Incorporated in
the DNA of every cell type in The
Offspring we know that there are about
80 genes with germline mutations that
predispose cells to cancer breast cancer
is is a good example of that
out of all the cancer genes to date so
um we know that about 20 have germline
mutations and about 10 show both somatic
and germline mutations now given that
germline mutations give rise to a
hereditary form of cancer that's present
in every single cell type of the body
this is an excellent starting point for
understanding tissue specificity of of
cancer
so just to give you an example consider
breaker one so bracha one we know
functions as a tumor suppressor we know
that mutations in bracha 1 are linked to
hereditary breasts and also ovarian
cancers as a gene product racquet one is
involved in repairing DNA
double-stranded breaks and it's involved
in mismatch repair
so mutations in bracha 1 account for
overwhelming number of hereditary breast
ovarian cancers and the interesting
thing is that women who have brachial 1
mutations that they've inherited have
that mutation in every single cell type
of their body and yet they develop
cancer in the breast and and or ovaries
so it's an interesting question as to
what is occurring in the other organs
and the other tissues that are buffering
this brachial one mutation
another piece of the puzzle is that
racqueline is highly expressed it's
known to be highly expressed in many
different cell types not just the
breasts and the ovaries and that
expression occurs both at the transcript
and the protein level so it's not a
simple matter of racquet one being
deactivated or repressed in terms of
expression in these cell types that
leads to the difference response we see
of developing cancer and not developing
cancer
so what we wanted to do was answer this
specific question how is that going
normally regulated in different tissues
as a way of understanding what happens
in the presence of cancer why bracawan
people with broccoline mutations only
get cancer in breast or ovaries
so what we've done is we've tried to
contrast the tissue specific regulatory
networks in different kinds of healthy
tissues that involve raccoon to really
get at the tissue specific Network
differences that might allow a cell to
buffer a raccoon generation
and so really
um as I as stated we're trying to
understand how some tissues are able to
tolerate these germline mutations better
than others and our goal is to
reconstruct
um Based on data resources that I'll
explain uh soon and analyze these tissue
specific Gene networks to understand
what the local network components are
contributing towards the development of
susceptibility or resistance to cancer
that we observe in these different
tissues
so basically just really quickly the
kind of workflow that we've stepped
through in our analysis is first of all
to identify the set of cancer-causing
germline mutated genes that we know
about we've then gone ahead and found
out which of those genes are associated
with tissue specific tumors and also
tissue specific expression profiles
we've then gone ahead and built a
protein protein and traction and
transcription Factor networks around
those genes which have been shown to
cause
tumor tissue specific tumors and also be
expressed across a wide range of
different tissues and then we've gone on
and looked at what functional insights
can be gained by contrasting these Gene
sets and these Gene Networks
so first of all uh we use the cancer
Gene census as a resource for
identifying the set of cancer genes with
germline mutations
the cancer Gene census is a resource
available from the from Sangha it's a
catalog of genes that have been
identified as having a causal role in
cancer and interestingly more than one
percent of all human genes have been
implicated in cancer via mutation so the
census is regularly updated it's a
really good resource that it contains a
lot of other aspects related to cancer
not just whether they're involved in
germline mutations
um in terms of looking at penetrants we
know of course that not all tissues
carrying the same genuine mutation will
go on to develop cancer
um
so some general mutations are associated
with Cancers that are highly tissue
specific like bracha one but there are
also others where the cancers affect
tissues more ubiquitously so it's
important in looking at this analysis to
define a property that we refer to as
tissue specific penetrants and this
reflects the ubiquity of the tumors in
terms of the tissues that they affect
um and we've actually used a
quantitative definition here where we
Define tissue-specific penetrants as the
property observing a larger number of
tumors associated with Gemma mutations
that are occurring in one or two tissue
groups and I'll expand on that in the
next few slides
so in terms of identifying and assessing
tissue specific penetrants are the
results we've turned to here is to use
Cosmic a cosmic stands for the catalog
of somatic mutations in cancer and even
though it's got somatic in the title it
actually contains germline mutations as
well so essentially Cosmic extends the
cancer Gene senses it contains a lot of
information from the literature on
cancer samples um
including their penetrance
and observation in different tissue
categories so Cosmic has declared 40
standardized tissue categories that
cover the entire human body and what
we're interested in looking at is
essentially coverage of the number of
mutations that have been reported for a
specific Gene and the exclusivity or the
um
tissue specificity that's been observed
so to give you an idea of what I mean
this is the tissue specific profile for
tp53 and it's kind of hard to read but
going across the x-axis are the 40
different tissue specific categories
that Cosmic is using and the along the
y-axis is the tissue percentage so that
reflects the percentage between zero and
of mutations that have been reported in
p53 that are exclusive to that specific
tissue group so you can see that the
tissue percentage bounces around quite a
bit across the different tissue
categories
um and that really reflects the ubiquity
of p53 mutations that we we know about
already the tissue specific name that
showed in red
um it's kind of fake but you can see the
the points that across the the graph
um this reflects the average of all
tissue percentages for all genes that
are in the cosmic database
and the reason why this is important is
because different tissue categories do
have different rates of coverage or
different numbers or sizes in the cosmic
database and I think this speaks to the
fact that some tissues are easier to
collect than others so in declaring
tissue specific penetrants we've used
the tissue mean
um or the the global tissue mean that's
based off all of the genes in the
database as a way of declaring whether a
gene is tissue specific or not
to give you a further idea of what I
mean we can contrast the profile of tk33
with bracha 1. so here you can see that
the three
um the three
tissue groups where tissue the tissue
percentage is very high for bracawan are
actually breast lung and ovary moving
from left to right along the x-axis
and what we've done here is
we've declared we've used our cut off
um such to declare a
Gene that's tissue specific if it's
tissue percentage profile is higher than
the global mean so you can see here that
for breast and ovary the tissue
percentage is higher than the tissue
mean whereas for lung it's not and again
I think this stays to the fact that
there are a lot of lung tissues in the
cosmic database so this is a way to
prevent being biased towards that sort
of selection um
that's available so our question now is
um
we mentioned to find out what network
properties that could be predisposing
breast and ovary towards developing
cancer that are not present in the other
tissues that we're looking at
so when we look at all the genes that we
have germline mutations for the pre
predisposed towards cancer there are
about 70 76 I believe that last count
and we use the criteria such
as when we looked Rebecca one to say how
many tissues have a tissue percentage
that's higher than the global tissue
mean if that number is one or two then
we consider that Gene to be tissue
specific
um in its penetrance for cancer and so
when we look at the genes
the 76 genes that have General mutations
predisposing for cancer we see that most
germline mutations are associated with
tissue specific tumors and here I've got
a graph that just shows you which genes
fall into the number of tissues that
genes mutated in so we see all the way
at the end of the spectrum here we see
p53 that's mutated in eight tissues and
on the left we see bracha 1 bracket two
Etc that are in the lower end of tissues
that have mutations in genes that are
mutated in
so really what we've got now we've got
two
we've got two properties of tissue
specific
um
to to tissue specific properties sorry
um we've got tissues for specific
penetrants uh like racquet one is is
specific for breasts and ovaries and we
all also have this concept of ubiquitous
versus tissue specific gene expression
and so our goal is to put these two
properties together and consider
um which
genes that are
tissue specific
in the penetrance but highly expressed
across different tissues like breast
ovary and brain to understand how it is
these tissues are buffering the tissue
specific effect
so I should just step back a little bit
and explain how we look at tissue
specific expression now the resource
that we're using is a resource that came
to us via our collaborators in the
Phantom 5 Consortium now Phantom 5 is an
international project that's being led
by the Rican omic Science Center in
Yokohama in Japan and the goal of a
fantasized Consortium is to construct a
complete promoter map that defines all
the different tissues in the human body
so as part of this project Phantom 5
have collected over a thousand human
primary tissues and cell lines and
they've analyzed these by mapping the
promoters for these different tissue
types and they've done this mapping
using a technology called heliscope cage
so cage stands for capped analysis and
gene expression and this is a single
molecule sequencing method there's no
amplification step required and
basically what it does is it sequences
the five Prime cap of every single mRNA
so in this way we can localize
where a promoter where transcription
starts and we can also use this in a
quantitative fashion where the number of
tags that map to a promoter start site a
transcription start site reflects the
degree of activation of that Gene or the
expression of that chain so this is how
we're looking at
tissue specific tissue wide gene
expression
and just to give you an idea
um we can look at expression across all
of the different tissues that are in the
fatter five cage data and just to show
you here are two examples of a tissue
specific
um Gene which is ALK ALK is involved in
neuroblastoma so germline mutations in
Oak lead to a neuroblastoma
and you can see it's got this very
picked kind of expression that reflects
the tissue specificity across the entire
Atlas on the other hand we have a more
ubiquitously expressed a gene which is
bracket two which we know also leads to
a cancer in the breast and the ovaries
and here you can see a much broader
profile the level of Racket two
expressions and a wider range of gene
expression values across the tissue
Atlas
so what we want to do is we want to
identify the different classes of genes
that are involved in tissue specific or
ubiquitous gene expression as well as
link those back to genes that we know
cause cancer in a specific set of tumors
versus more broadly in the human body
so what we've done is we've declared
four different classes that speak to
these different tissue specific
properties we have class one which is
the set of genes that have a mutation
that causes tumors in a specific tissue
and is expressed only in that tissue we
have class 2 genes which reflect those
genes that have a mutation causing
tumors in a tissue-wide or ubiquitous
matter and they're also expressed across
a ubiquitous tissues
and finally we have class three which
represents our most interesting class
because this is a set of genes that
cause cancer in a restricted set of
tissues
but are expressed ubiquitously so for
instance like raccoon and So based on
our 76 I believe a germline mutation
genes we've classified which of those
fall into our different tissue specific
groups
um and let me just step back a little
bit and explain how we came out with
that classification
um we've already come up with a tissue
specific penetrance definition but what
we also needed to do was come up with a
way to define or classify which genes
fell into the tissue specific expression
category versus the ubiquitous
expression and so
um this as you've as we saw with the
contrasting profiles is really a matter
of declaring skewness we saw that genes
that have a very skewed profile when we
look at their expression in the entire
Phantom 5 tissue Atlas correspond to
tissue specific expression whereas
Genesis have a much broader profile are
more likely to be ubiquitous so we
solved this problem of identifying
tissue specific patterns by using mixed
models so we used the m-class r package
to fit mixtures or normal mixtures based
on the Assumption of equal variants and
the goal is to try and capture the
number of underlying tissues specific or
tissue related states that are present
for each gene
so just to give you an idea of what I
mean we fit for a gene expression
profile we fit a number of mixture
models depending on on what the data
says and our rule is that if the
critical regions from these separate
mixtures overlap then the gene is
classified as ubiquitous otherwise if we
have Extreme More extreme mixtures such
that they define specific sets of tissue
specific expression then they're
classified as tissue specific so this
gives us a way to control for the error
involved to a degree and of course what
happens you might ask is we if we have
more than two mixtures well in that case
we adopt or extend the rules such that
for any two adjacent mixtures these have
to be non-overlapping in order to
declare a tissue a gene to have a tissue
specific expression and profile so this
is the rule that we've implemented to
come up with our four classes and as you
can see here these are the the four
classes the genes that are involved in
each of these four classes
we are most interested in class three
primarily because this is the group of
genes represent the potential the most
potential for buffering effects to be
occurring within a regulatory Networks
so one thing we've done is to really try
to understand what these genes doing and
how they're contributing to this
buffering role if we step back and look
at significant functional trends that
are available or are detected in these
Gene sets we see that ubiquitously
expressed genes tend to be tumor
suppressors and that's based off looking
at go enrichment keg enrichment um
analyzes we see terms that like cell
cycle DNA repair cell adhesion come up
which are really characteristic of genes
involved in tumor suppression we've also
looked at lists that have been annotated
from the literature with regards to
whether these genes are involved in
tumor suppressor versus oncogenic
functions we also see for the tissue
specific Express genes that they have go
and keg terms that speak to oncogenic
function like proliferation
differentiation migration and survival
and the interesting thing is that class
3 genes are populated with tumor
suppressor tumor suppressor genes
so as I said in in terms of class 3
genes our underlying hypothesis that we
want to test is that tissue specific
networks are somehow buffering genes
with germline mutation locally so if you
take for instance this is just a cartoon
but if you take for instance the braco
one network for a resistant tissue which
is not press not ovary and you contrast
that network with a network from a
susceptible tissue like the breast or
ovary you would see local differences
that in these networks that would confer
some sort of buffering capability in the
event of a geminine mutation in racca1
so what we've done then is to construct
protein protein and traction networks
and we've done that using a resource
called irf Index this is a database that
combines all the information we have
available with respect to protein
protein interactions and there is a
corresponding r package available called
IFR
and we've also combined this information
with tissue specific resources so
there's a database called tiger which
comes from Johns Hopkins and it
represents tissue specific gene
expression and regulatory information
and of course we've also used the tissue
Outlets from Phantom 5. so this is these
two networks are real PPI networks that
we've reconstructed for the small
intestine on the left and for the breast
on the right and the central protein
even though I know it's hard to see is
the is braco one so it is difficult to
make out topological differences just
because there's so much going on in
these networks but there are differences
that we're starting to see when we look
at contrasting these networks directly
and so one of these differences is in
looking at degree or connectivity of
bracawan
protein in in these networks and so what
you see here is the degree distribution
across all of the 40 different tissue
specific categories
and the yellow bars represent the degree
of racquet one in the ovarian and breast
tissue and actually the green bars
represent the connectivity in
corresponding cancer tissues so we also
had access to some
different kinds of cancer cancer lines
and cancer samples in Phantom five and
so you can see oh the other thing I
should mention too is the three
different lines correspond to the data
that we have from the two different
resources so we have the degree
distribution just from the tiger
networks Phantom 5 and by combining
these two resources as well so the
immediate thing is that there aren't
there is actually a lot of consistency
um as we go from left to right we see
some differences in that number but that
number is not bouncing around
um and certainly for ovarian and breast
networks uh that there isn't a huge
amount of difference compared to some of
the others but this graph does tell us
that there are some extreme tissues on
the end
um
I believe
for instance like lung tissue eye tissue
that there are differences in
connectivity for the back of one protein
so we can look more carefully at this
network as well and look at what the
other genes or Gene products that black
one is connected to and look for
functional roles for these genes as a
set and so when we do going keg
enrichment we see that some of the tones
that bubble to the surface are related
to DNA double-strand repair and mismatch
repair now this is um this is not a
hugely surprising result we know that
bracket1 is involved in DNA damage
response and obviously interacts with
other proteins to form these complexes
that are involved in DNA damage response
we are seeing the signature pop-up both
in this situation and other analyzes as
well such as the class 3 set of genes
themselves and so it's it's leading us
to
think that DNA damage pathways are
playing a role in normal tissues to set
up some of the susceptibility to cancer
that's occurring differently in
different tissues and this makes a lot
of sense because
we know that different tissues even in a
normal setting are subject to different
levels of DNA damage so it makes a lot
of sense that these tissues are using
these DNA damage Pathways differently
and such that in the presence of a
germline mutation that affects all
tissues that you may see a different
response such that some tissues go on to
develop cancer whereas some others are
able to remain resistant and be robust
so another thing we did to cut down the
uh the the huge number of proteins that
we're seeing in these PPI networks was
to identify key components or what we're
calling gene expression hugs and these
are genes that when you compare their
gene expression levels in breast tissue
normal breast tissue compared to other
resistant tissues that there's a
statistically significant difference at
the point of five levels but also that
we're seeing these genes are highly
connected in the black and white Network
so we've used arbitrary cutoff of 100
interactions
and when we're after this filtering what
we're left with is a smaller Network
which I've shown here and it might be
hard to see but there's some interesting
genes that bubble to the surface so for
instance F1 Alpha Jack one these are all
genes that have previously been involved
in in cancer and so this where it seems
like they're involved here
differentially
in different tissues so we've also done
this with
cancer tissue and there's a mistake here
in my slide we haven't looked at normal
breast tissue what we've actually looked
at is cancer breast tissue in normal
resistant tissues so those definitely
those terms should be flipped I
apologize for that but basically what we
did was we took breast cancer tissue
cancer breast a breast cancer tissue and
we compared it to normal resistant
tissues and we looked again at genes
that had a statistically significant
difference in expression and also were
highly connected in over a hundred other
interactions in the PPI Network and it's
difficult to see the labels here in this
network but there are some interesting
genes here such as egr1 TP 73 and the
Androgen receptor as well
so we're in the process of exploring
this feather and talking to our cancer
biology collaborators
so
another thing we've done too is we've
looked at some other networks or begun
to look at some other networks protein
protein interaction networks are useful
but they fail to capture some of the
other more targeted regulatory
relationships that we know exist and one
way of getting at that is to look at
transcription Factor Networks so we've
used
um the network that's come out of Mara
Mara is a method for Network
reconstruction that's been developed by
our Phantom 5 collaborators and they've
used Mara on the Phantom 5 tissue
Outlets to construct a global TF Network
within this Global Network we've looked
at connectivity
that's associated with cracker one as
well as other genes that have Gemini
mutations and what was what we've seen
is there are again some differences that
are parent in these transcription Factor
networks between susceptible and
resistant tissue specific networks but
we're really only at the beginning of
looking at what these differences are
another thing we've done is to extend
our classifiers to make predictions
about what other genes in the human
genome
would be in terms of their tissue
specific classes and so basically what
we've done is we've used data in Cosmic
which is a genome-wide resource as well
as the information in the Phantom 5
tissue Atlas
to predict sets of tissue specific genes
and what we've done here is just shown
the number of genes that fall into these
classes and we'll be making this
available from our website soon but the
idea is to classify which genes might be
involved in tissue specific tumors as
well as have tissue specific expression
this provides a resource for trying to
understand which genes might be more
tissue ubiquitous versus tissue specific
um
finally
we've looked Within These class
predictions to look for any significant
functional terms that are coming up
um one thing that's been interesting
within class three class three three
genes are those genes that are involved
in tissue specific tumors but are
expressed ubiquitously
um and they they are potentially
involved in buffering the response one
term that came out that was quite
interesting was ubiquitination and it
could be that buffering mechanisms may
be occurring through these these kinds
of mechanisms like ubiquitination so
that's something that we're interested
in following up
um I'd like to finish up my talk then
and conclude with some of the results
that we're seeing so far so the goal was
to understand why resistant tissues are
able to buffer a germline mutation
better than other susceptible tissues
that go on to develop cancer we looked
for clues to answer this question in how
tissue specific networks control cancer
genes in normal tissues a range of
normal tissues we identified a set of
class 3 genes needs of genes that have
broad ubiquitous expression but are
involved in a restricted subset of
tissues and we use these clustering
genes as candidates to look at local
network changes that are occurring in
normal tissues and to try and understand
how different network configurations can
contribute to cancer developing in some
of these tissues versus others for
raccoon and it seems for other other
genes too DNA damage Pathways may be one
of the distinguishing variables between
resistant and susceptible tissues and
this makes a lot of sense given that
different tissues in a normal setting
are subjected require
DNA damage Pathways DNA damage response
Pathways sorry to differing degrees
so um but finally we've looked at
differentially expressed and highly
connected nodes in these local tissue
specific networks in the protein protein
interaction networks and they may be
candidates for also contributing to
driving this distinction
so I'm gonna end there
um by acknowledging the people that
we've been working with and the people
who did this work my postdoc Dr Danny
cabaho has done largely all these
analyzes
um we've also been working in
collaboration with people at the Recon
omics Science Center in Yokohama
specifically Dr Aleister Forest
um Dr McHale dehoon and also other
people from the LSA bioinformatics group
I'd like to end there by thanking again
the organizers by a conference live for
the invitation to be able to talk about
our work I'd like to thank you for your
participation your attention during this
talk and I'd just like to remind you
that if you are interested in getting
CME credits uh the the quiz is available
I believe at this website and I'd be
happy and delighted to take any
questions that you might have
so let me just have a look
okay so the first question we have is
have these type of analogies been made
on mice models with germo mutations one
could manipulate them genetically Etc
um
that is a really great question uh we
haven't looked at Mouse models we've
been looking at
human data I should just mention that
the Phantom pipe tissue Atlas has host
cell lines as well as primary tissues
primary tissues have been collected from
three different people with replicates
I've
I've armed so there is a level of I
guess natural variation there but it
certainly would be a lot cleaner and a
lot more controlled to look at Mouse
models particularly for the external
mutations and as as you mentioned
manipulate them genetically I believe
that
for the 1776 Drumline genes with General
mutations that probably has been a lot
of the mouse work
done on on these genes so it would be
interesting to take that data and
combine it and apply these kinds of
analyzes but that's something we we
haven't had the opportunity to do so far
the second question that's been
submitted is how about comparing
networks in breast tissue of very early
onset women versus very late onset women
with
that is a fantastic question
um and I think that really speaks to the
next steps of why we're trying to do
this work is to be able to understand
how it is that the robustness starts to
break down
um specifically because we're looking at
normal tissue to begin with and
understand you know how that robustness
breaks down to lead to the development
of cancer I think the fact that we
haven't been able to do that is is
largely because it's difficult to get
access to that data
but that would certainly be very
interesting to do that Network
comparison
and the final question is were these
comparisons done in silicone analysis or
in wet lab
this this data was these comparisons
were done on
I guess in silica in the sense that it's
all been computational statistical
analysis reviews data that's come from
wet lab approaches but we haven't also
been able to go back and validate them
via experimental methods
so if there aren't any more questions
um I'm going to end there and thank you
again for your participation and
attention today